well joining me now to discuss the
situation in the country dr ramirez alec
barrow the u.n secretary general's
deputy special representative for
afghanistan who is currently in kabul
thank you so much for joining us this
afternoon here on sky news and for many
of our viewers watching that report it
really highlights
the plight of the people of afghanistan
we're talking about
the majority of the population on the
brink of starvation and needing medical
assessment talk to me about
what you're doing
to help address the issues highlighted
in that report
thank you so much for inviting me and
covering this
heartbreaking story which we witness
here on the ground every day
in last winter
more than 20 million people have
received food assistance
from our food sector partners
it is thanks to this assistant that the
starvation scenario
in winter of 2021 2022 was largely
avoided
but through the current state of uh
economy
with the paralyzed economic activity
banking sector closed
our estimates now indicate that more
than 19 million people right now
are in the state of malnutrition
out of this
6.6 million people are in state of
accurate malnutrition
half of the children under five
are starving or being heavily
malnourished in other words
so what we're doing is that we're
bringing the food supplies uh we are
organizing medical treatment throughout
the country but our resources are not
sufficient
the hrp the humanitarian response plan
is only 50 funded for this even less
and we need so much more
to respond and to prepare for the next
winter
afghanistan needs so much more on all
fronts i mean we were looking at
medical assistance there hospitals
cannot cope you know the majority of
them will have to shut down if something
if something drastic doesn't happen
within the next few months
you've touched their on the famine in
the country they're on the brink of
famine um human rights i was talking
earlier on to two women who made it out
of kabul and who are desperate to keep
the plight of women and girls in the
country
at the top of the news agenda
you're trying to help afghanistan on so
many fronts does the situation sometimes
do you seem
impossible
it is uh and then
let's be honest this is a very poor
country it has very
low level of development overall
it's predominantly rural and the rural
areas
are not very well developed
so we have choice of
facing this situation every year where
the 20 million people will be in a very
difficult shape or change the strategy
and try to work towards
some sort of recovery of agrofood
systems sector
by creating a few million very basic
jobs in the farming sector that will
start to use
local food but that would require
different type of investment
and it takes time to build these
investments and this is irrigation
systems
connecting people uh to to the market
building storage facilities for food
supporting farmers with machinery to
produce that food so create an agrofood
systems and link people to the market so
they will feed themselves but we're not
there yet that requires also a different
type of approach and in the current
political environment the developmental
like investments are limited
we are resorting to humanitarian
response but humanitarian response will
not resolve the problems of afghanistan
which are systemic and related to the
backwardness of afghan village and to
the lack of overall development of the
country yeah can we touch on the
political world because
the taliban government is shutting the
international community the
international community to a certain
extent is very much channing that
shutting the the taliban a leg country
of afghanistan is there a political will
from the international community to help
afghan people the people that that we've
seen on the screen this afternoon who
are starving in hospitals what can be
done
look
in this difficult situation i could say
in a globally difficult situation the
world did not abandon afghanistan we
still have received billions of dollars
of assistance
and i also believe that the de facto
authorities have to make better strides
in convincing the international
community that the right act
specifically by bringing girls back to
school and taking the right steps
towards the women's participation in the
economy
which is a very very simple act and that
will bring a lot of resources back into
the economy so that there would be a
mutual movement towards edge goals which
are shared
but let's face it uh the recent
developments it's it's been difficult to
convince the good people of the world
that
it is a good cause to support
afghanistan and the problem is exactly
what we have said it is not the taliban
it's not the de facto authorities who
are on the taking side of this
catastrophe it's the ordinary people the
ordinary people who have uh no
association or or anything to do with
the political developments of the last
years
uh dr ram is alex borov i think your
heavy site at the start of that answer
pretty much uh summed up the difficult
uh job that you have and so many others
have trying to help the people of
afghanistan and thank you for speaking
to us u.s secretary general's deputy
special representative for afghanistan
we appreciate you taking the time thank
you